The size of a circuit
corresponds to the number of elementary operations
we need to perform.
So if we were to perform
those operations sequentially and the size would tell
us how long it would take,
so you can think about a circuit size as representing sequential running time.
This is going to be how we
measure computational cost for the purposes of this lesson.
There is another property
of circuits though that can also be viewed as the amount of time
required to run a circuit, and that's the circuit's depth.
To be precise, the depth
is the maximum number of gates encountered on any path from an input wire to an output wire,
which is equivalent to the number of layers of gates we need
to create the circuit, where a layer refers to a bunch of gates
that could be performed simultaneously because they don't have
any wires in common.
For example, our circuit
from before has depth four, and we can see directly from the diagram that there are four layers.
The FANOUT gates can be
performed simultaneously, the NOT gates can be
performed simultaneously and the AND gates can be
performed simultaneously as well.
So we can think about circuit depth as representing parallel running time.
Circuit depth is certainly an interesting and important notion and there are some very
sophisticated techniques that can be used to reduce
the depth required for some computations, sometimes quite dramatically, in fact, but it's an advanced topic
and we're not gonna have too much more to say about it in this series.
So once again, we'll
measure computational cost in terms of circuit
size or in other words,
the number of elementary operations required to perform a computation.
At the beginning of the lesson, we talked about the integer
factorization problem and we saw that the time required for an algorithm to solve this problem
can increase as inputs grow in length, and this is typically
the issue we focus on
when we're analyzing algorithms.
That is, we're interested in how the costs of running algorithms scale as inputs get larger and larger.
Of course, this sort of scaling isn't the only thing that matters.
For example, we may simply be interested in finding the factors
of RSA1024 and that's it.
So in a case like that, we'd be talking about a
single problem instance where nothing is growing.
But when we're thinking about algorithms, the way that their costs
scale matters a great deal and it tells us a lot
about the algorithms.
This point of view is
consistent with the idea that algorithms are fundamental, and as I talked about before,
as time goes on and technology advances, they will be deployed against
larger and larger inputs.
But notice that while inputs to computational problems
can grow in size, circuits don't grow.
Each circuit has a fixed size.
And for that reason, if we want to describe an
algorithm using circuits, we're actually going to need a family of circuits to do that,
and by a family of circuits, we mean a collection of circuits that gets larger and larger so that we can accommodate inputs
as they get larger and larger. For example, let's consider a classical deterministic algorithm
for the integer factorization problem, maybe one based on trial division, but the specifics don't really matter
for the sake of this example.
We could in principle
describe such an algorithm using a family of Boolean circuits where if we want to factor a number
whose binary representation has N-bits, we grab the circuit CN from our family and we input the number
that we want to factor
into the input bits of that circuit.
Sometimes we might choose to parameterize these
circuits in different ways, so it might not always be the case that the Nth circuit has N input bits,
but that's a pretty typical way to do it. Naturally, as the input
lengths get longer, we would expect the circuits
in this family to get larger
reflecting the fact that
factoring four bit numbers is a lot easier than factoring 1,024 bit numbers, for instance.
And so, with that in mind, we measure the cost of such
an algorithm by a function, which tells us how many
elementary operations
we need for each possible input length, and we can do this for both classical and quantum algorithms.
As an example, let's consider the problem of integer addition, which is certainly much
simpler than factoring
or even competing GCDs.
Just to keep things simple, let's suppose that both N and
M are non-negative integers and that they're represented
by binary strings having the same length.
How might we build Boolean circuits that add these two numbers together?
Well, let's start with an algorithm, the standard algorithm for addition, which is the base two analog of the method
that I presume we all learned for adding numbers together with a
pencil and a piece of paper, so we start with the
least significant bits,
add them together, and that gives us the least
significant bit of the result along with a carry bit
that we have to consider
when we move to the next position. And we continue moving through the bits, generating output bits
along with carry bits
until we get to the end.